Alors Technophobe c'est un court-métrage que j'ai écrit, qui est censé raconter l'histoire d'un mec qui devient allergique à la technologie
Et Julien m'a un petit peu aidé sur l'écriture
C'est vrai que la thématique des nouvelles technologies, ça revient très souvent dans mes vidéos
Je me suis vraiment dit
Un jour, mais
Comment faire sans ?
Et si par exemple un mec tout seul ne pouvait pas utiliser de technologies
Il n'y a pas de moral puisqu'à la fin tout le monde devient allergique
Imaginons, dans un monde où on peut plus utiliser de technologies malheureusement
Phobie de la technologie
Excuse moi
Y eu quatre jours et demi de tournage
Moi c'était le plus gros tournage que j'ai pu faire
En plus vraiment, de 6h du matin jusqu'à parfois 23h donc c'était des bonnes grosses journées
Euh, mais bon y avait une équipe de ouf
Et franchement, c'était vraiment super
J'adore tourner avec Julien
J'adore tourner avec Ludovic, avec Julien Pestel aussi
Tous ces gens là qui sont tous là dans cette vidéo
Donc ça c'était vraiment chouette
Et en plus l'équipe, je les connais très très bien
Nous voilà chez mamie
C'est comme ça que s'appelle le décor
C'est la maison de ma grand-mère
Faut savoir qu'on est à une heure de Paris
Je sais même pas si c'est toujours la France ici, je crois qu'on a passé la douane
C'est une blague
Et on va tourner du coup avec euh
Claudette
Qui va faire ma grand-mère
Claudette c'est quelqu'un qui va tourner souvent avec le réalisateur
Et quand je lui ai dit qu'il fallait une grand-mère dedans
Il m'a fait
On prend Claudette direct
C'est un peu la mamie qu'on s'échange
Voilà, euh
Hors contexte ça fait bizarre comme ça mais
Je voulais pas spécialement des guest dans cette vidéo
Mais je pouvais m'empêcher de demander à des gens quand même
Et je sais qu'il fallait une journaliste donc j'ai demandé à Laurence Ferrari
que j'ai rencontré, y a pas si longtemps
Ensuite j'ai demandé à Maurice Barthélémy s'il voulait bien faire une apparition
Moi je suis un grand grand fan de Maurice Barthélémy mais vraiment
Quand j'étais gamin je regardais tous les Robin des Bois
Tous ces films
J'avais même appelé, quand j'avais 13/14 ans j'avais appelé tous les Maurice Barthélémy qu'il y avait dans l'annuaire à Paris
Pour essayer de tomber sur lui
Je suis pas tombé sur lui mais bien évidemment, 10 ans plus tard j'ai pu le rencontrer
Je lui ai montré ça, le script
Et il trouvait ça chouette et il a bien voulu faire du coup le médecin
Et c'était très dur de garder son sérieux sans exploser de rire
Encore
Donne ton oreille
Alors c'est une fin de tournage pour Maurice Barthélémy
Oui
J'avais parlé de réaliser un rêve de gosse
Qui est de tourner avec lui
Avec un vieux
Tourner avec une personne agée
Tout le plaisir est pour moi
Non c'est vrai, ça m'a fait super plaisir
Moi je suis Cyprien depuis que j'ai 8 ans
J'ai vu tous tes films, j'ai même assisté à ta naissance
Ouais
Et franchement ça me touche
Dans le script, y avait écrit :
Julien essaye des objets sur Arthur
C'était.. Y avait juste écrit ça et ensuite il se rend compte qu'il devient allergique à la technologie
Après y avait quelles lignes mais ...
Et du coup on s'est retrouvé finalement
À 40 minutes de rush
De Julien qui teste des objets sur moi
Une banane, un truc
Tu peux ça
Non mais ça va, rigole roh
Chiant le mec. En humour t'as pas gagné non plus
Le seul regret que j'ai eu
C'est, on a tourné une séquence de nuit dans mon appart'
Et j'ai oublié d'enlever mes lunettes
Le personnage d'Arthur ne porte pas de lunettes
C'était la seule différence avec moi, c'est juste j'enlevais mes lunettes
Comme tout le monde a l'habitude de me voir avec des lunettes
Ils ont pas tilté qu'il fallait que je les enlève
On a tout tourné
Ok ! Coupé ! C'est bien tout le monde !
Et là on rend les clés du décor
Et là je me rend compte qu'en fait, j'avais oublié de les enlever
Je fais "Est-ce qu'on peut retourner ? "
Et là on se rend compte qu'en fait non, on a plus de décors, c'est terminé
Du coup voilà
Mon personnage a des problèmes de vu à un moment
Voilà, on va faire avec
Fin de tournage, ouais !
Et là on est au mixage
Donc c'est pas compliqué
Sur le tournage y avait des micros partout
Donc en fait la technique de mixage c'est de tout réunir
Et essayer bah qu'on entende tout et qu'on comprenne
On voulait essayer de comme dans les films classique
Essayer d'avoir un thème récurrent, un sorte de like motiv qui revient sur tous les films
Ça fait
Ouais c'est un peu funky
Quand j'ai pas de contrainte, je sais pas où aller
Là t'as une contrainte et en fait par la contrainte
tu pousses t'as créativité
C'est fou de voir autant de gens s'investirent comme ça
à pleins de niveaux
sur une idée qui a germé dans mon esprit
c'est vraiment chouette et je pense en refaire dès que possible, tout simplement
Au revoir